la réserve naturelle de saint quentin en
yvelines est une résine naturelle en ito
logique c'est véritablement la richesse
ornithologique qui est présente sur ce
site et donc vous pouvez venir voir
facilement les oiseaux vivre à l'étang
saint quentin donc c'est en un mot c'est
ça sûrement la réserve aux oiseaux c'est
peu dire oui la volonté la fonction
première d'une réserve naturelle c'est
d'accueillir des espèces qui sont rares
et menacées et protégées
donc les oiseaux qui viennent ici sont
des oiseaux rares et les connaisseurs
savent très bien qui peut voir ici en
ile-de-france des oiseaux convoité on va
dire et donc pourquoi ils sont ici c'est
parce que la réserve leurs portes
quiétude une tranquillité qui n'ont pas
forcément ailleurs sur territoire et
donc du coup bah on peut les on peut les
voir alors bien sûr en toute discrétion
on a aménagé des observatoires pour se
faire discret pour bien observer cette
richesse ornithologique
[Musique]
en ce moment on est en pleine période de
reproduction donc vous pouvez avoir des
espèces migratrices qui viennent se
produire sur le site vous avez levé
comme sombre et des hangars de voeux
vous avez là du plongeur snacks et qui
est attendu on a la bonne nouvelle pour
nos 35 ans que la réserve naturelle de
saint quentin fête ses 35 ans cette
année de changer de d'envergure puisque
en fait on aujourd'hui la réserve existe
sur 14 11 hectares sur 150 ans sur la
partie ouest pour ceux qui la
connaissent aujourd'hui elle pas inclure
une plus grande réserve naturelle
la réserve naturelle des états en rigole
donc vous allez pouvoir aller sur et en
d2 est classé en réserve naturelle sur
la chaîne des étangs de hollande
l'étang de saint-hubert corbel pour à ce
petit hollande et une partie des étangs
de la tour et du perray
ainsi que quelques rigoler à dupont sont
maintenant placés aussi réserve
naturelle nationale comme l'était cinq
ans tendu